Trolling,
uh,
certainly the topic of the year,
if we were having this conversation in
1995 for one thing,
the screen would be about one 16th.
The size and the video quality would be
much poorer,
but it would be a very standard
configuration.
The story would be,
hey,
there's now an internet.
People can say anything.
Sometimes it gets a little out of
control and maybe the government will
come in and try to regulate in some way,
but it's basically the government is
trying to stop illegal or really extreme
things from happening and otherwise it's
just a free for all out there.
I'm away.
We go fast forward 10,
15,
20 years and we see an environment now
in which many many people want to
participate,
maybe have used.
They want to share and if you stick your
head up out of the gopher hole and it
happened to say something in temperate
or wrong or that others may disapprove
of,
they might not just say,
Gee,
I disagree.
Let's,
let's talk about this.
Or something.
They may decide to try to docs.
You find out where you live,
the names of the rest of your family to
threaten you with the goal of making you
feel insecure.
They might try to swat you,
tell the police that there's something
terrible going on in your house and
before you know it,
there's blue and red lights outside your
window and people ready to kick in the
door.
This is a strange state of affairs and
it's one I think with multiple causes
and that actually is susceptible to
pretty sustained study,
most of which hasn't happened yet in the
next few years.
I think it will.
That says what makes people want to
react that way.
My best cut on it at the most abstract
level is that when we are online,
we may be undertaking very different
activities and the people that we're
talking to.
One model for being online is I'm
entertaining myself.
I'm having fun.
I am in some form or another plane
again,
and if that's the case,
playing the game means picking aside and
that's a very different model from.
I'm online because I really believe
earnestly and something and I want to
convince you of why I'm right or have
you maybe convince me or find people who
are of like mind and we can talk about
strategizing about the thing that we
really care about.
Those are totally different activities
and when you try to mix the two,
it's almost like saying if there's going
to be a discussion between Seattle
seahawks fans and New England patriots
fans ahead of a superbowl,
can't we just settle this with a
discussion like can't we just earnestly
era our differences and come to some
compromise that the patriots should win,
but only by five points.
Like that's nuts.
The purpose of the conversation is sort
of just the chest thumping that comes
from the play of being a fan of a team
and trash talking to the other team and
then,
you know,
you play the game.
I think that for a lot of trolling
there's a sense that it's just not
impersonal.
We're just out to have some fun.
Others have referred to this as four
Chan culture and uh,
of course named after the site four Chan
for which this is the largely the
culture figuring out I think,
how to have people avoid category errors
might be a good way to relieve a little
bit the initial conditions that give
rise to a situation that you fast
forward and somehow death or rape
threats are being made.
Personal information is getting
scattered everywhere and the parties
behind it still or just like think it's
no big deal.
Like they just go to sleep at night and
tomorrow they'll find a new cause to get
involved in.
I imagine we will also see some of these
intermediary platforms that are commonly
used for many purposes like twitter.
They're going to start taking a heavier
hand at intervening when discussions get
rough and it might be as simple as,
uh,
being more willing to delete accounts,
which let's be clear that's going to
mean that others will be more willing to
try to import tune twitter to delete
accounts as part of the battle,
uh,
between people who are arguing about
something over the longer term.
I think we may see coming into view
something has been promised for awhile
and uh,
be careful what you ask for.
I think we're going to get it,
which is to say some form of singular or
multi-platform reputation systems.
Think how different ones,
twitter or facebook experience might be.
If the feed is populated on the basis of
people who are known to participate with
a bare minimum of civility.
Let's define it easily as don't engage
in serious imminent death threats and if
you do,
you might not have your account deleted,
but you will find that the way in which
you tweet will not have the same reach
as people who either through the twitter
platform or through behavior on other
platforms that has been deemed a civil
and productive.
Those will start to get reach to and I.
I will say that once people kind of know
the basis on which they're being graded
can have a really instant effect on
their behavior.
Some of us may remember the moment that
uber mistakenly made it easy for
somebody to find his or her own rating
as a passenger by drivers on Uber,
drivers rate passengers,
not just the other way around,
and people are much more self conscious
now maybe about how they'll behave in an
uber if they want to retain a good
rating so that they will be more likely
to be picked up when they need a cab or
a ride in the future.
Those reputation systems both hold
promise as a way of having trolling the,
if not punished,
not rewarded,
good behavior,
whatever that means is the eyes of the
people rating.
I'm a rising you up in the scales and
giving you more reach a and of course
also carries with it a whole host of new
and difficult questions about,
well,
who runs this rating system?
And one of the people writing me or
raping me by criteria that are unfair,
that might be based on the color of my
skin or my ethnicity or something like
that that we could find rating systems
doing.
Now we're just not exactly there yet.
Uh,
so we have to see what are the solutions
that will come about problems like
trolling and one of the problems that
those solutions will raise.